foreign
we are back let's go out to Chris in
Huntsville what's up Chris
hey Dr John how are you doing I'm
rocking on to the break of dawn what are
you doing
oh just
Sitting Waiting for the kids to get out
of school
[Laughter]
good times just
that sounds sad Chris can't you be like
take disco dance lessons online or
something come on yeah I know I need to
I Knew first day back so all right all
right all right you get one day all
right so what's up how can I help
um
I overcome crushing self-doubt
um I'm feeling overwhelmed
with making some major life decisions
um I've been a stay-at-home mom for the
last
15 plus years and want to return to work
so I can get out of my abusive marriage
um
I had a work colleague recently reached
out to me to um
uh help me get a job
um and I've been extended an offer but
I'm quite scared to take it because I'm
not sure that I'm qualified or I'm going
to be able to do it
and I'm just um really scared that I'm
going to fail I don't want to let my
kids down
tell me about this marriage
um
it's uh
pretty much consists of
um
lots of uh silent treatment
um getting punished for I don't even
know what not saying the right thing or
not doing the right thing
um they'll go days or weeks without
speaking to me
um
a lot of violent outbursts not laying
hands on me but throwing things around
and
kick the dogs a couple of times and um
just
uh it's
this is and you just
he just says
bad things for kids too and I just know
that have you moved out
no we're still together
So when you say to get out of a bad
marriage or is step one getting this job
and securing finances and step two
moving out
yes okay does he know that or is this
just in internal
internal he doesn't know it okay
um
number one I Supply you
thanks
and you and I could probably talk for
another couple hours on this but
these almost always have an escalating
Trend to them and something tells me
that this has become something you can't
do anymore
yeah I think it's uh slowly killing me
yeah
my guess is it's probably fast killing
you
and you've got two um
two big bricks in your backpack number
one is stay-at-home moms are routinely
told that they are dumb and useless and
a drain on society and they should if
they had real worth they would go get
jobs and make real dollars that's that's
that's a global Society problem we have
it's nonsense and it's Insidious and
it's stupid but that's the way it is the
second thing is you've been married to a
a gigantic five-year-old child
you act like a brat and
um a violent brat and who throws things
and kicks things and swears at things
like like a child does
yeah in the process you have tried
for how long have y'all been married
16 years you've tried for 16 years
to be whatever he needed you to be so
he'd stop doing that
yeah and you're just now realizing oh
it's not me it never has been
yes exactly and so
when a confidence is a contrary to what
Tick Tock will tell you confidence is
not something you can just conjure
confidence is known inside your body
when it knows it can do a thing
and your confidence has been rattled to
the core because you've been trying to
figure out what you're doing so wrong
all these years and you don't have that
confidence
okay so in these initial weeks and
months and years as you are getting your
footing new firm footing on new concrete
sidewalks when you've been swimming in
muck and water and goo the last 16 years
what we're gonna do for a season is
we're going to Outsource that confidence
okay and I'm always telling people not
to Outsource their life but in this case
it's a little bit different
here's who you're going to Outsource it
to
a business is only in business if it
makes money
and so a good manager will hire the best
people
so that the business makes money so that
the business can continue
yeah and they looked at you
and they said she can help us
and so where you don't have confidence
know that they're not doing you a favor
they're not hooking you up that's not
how business works yeah
right if it was a church or a non-profit
maybe maybe they're trying to help you
out yeah this is a business
and they picked you
and so in the moments when you think I
can't do this remember they do
yeah they think I can
and by the way you've been a parent to
how many kids
two you've raised two humans and you've
protected them from a third giant child
for 16 years you can do just about any
freaking thing you want to do
and can I tell you one more thing yes oh
God you're gonna screw up so much
you're gonna screw up so much yeah
because you don't you've been out of the
workforce you got to learn
yeah I'm really scared
setting myself up for failure yeah so
let me tell you this don't be scared
about it because it's 100 gonna happen
you're gonna happen yeah
yeah so yeah it's like if if
I saw some data the other day that said
ah I don't remember I saw this but it's
pretty powerful
um people will do anything
to avoid uncertainty right so a 50
chance that something's gonna go great
or a 50 chance Something's Gonna go
wrong they would rather take the
percentage that a hundred percent of
things are going to go wrong
then live in the ambiguity that half
might go right half might go good which
statistically is insane that doesn't
make any sense right that's like I would
rather be a hundred percent bad then
this could go really great or I could go
really bad so I'm telling you there's a
hundred percent chance that you screw
stuff up and yeah there's a hundred
percent chance I have screwed things up
today in my job
that's okay
it's all right
all of us yeah that's part of doing
business that's part of the Great lie of
people outside of business who are
stay-at-home moms who are like oh I
could never go do that because I don't
have the dude no we're all making it up
as we go
oh you're gonna learn some incredible
new skills and you're going to transform
your life and I told this story several
times have you heard me tell a story of
my mom
actually I have not okay
um
she was not allowed no sorry oh it's
okay she wasn't allowed to go to college
okay for a whole host of reasons but she
wasn't allowed to go
so she got married to my dad who was a
homicide detective and she just settled
into being a stay-at-home mom and then
she transitioned to working like
stay-at-home mom and then like worked a
few hours a week at a local church like
in the craft office like making sure the
the construction paper is where it
needed to be and the pipe cleaners were
in the right drawer stuff like that
right and then she
um my dad was always encouraging her
please go to school please go to school
please go to school and finally at 42
she got the courage to go back I was a
freshman I think or maybe a um maybe a
sophomore but I think a freshman in high
school
she took her first community college
class and got an A
and she went the next semester and took
one more class at a local just down the
street from our house Community College
yeah that was a 42. yeah at 57 she
graduated with her PhD after working at
Enron and Deloitte and touch before
those two companies imploded
and right now she's in her 70s she just
had her birthday and she had her
birthday in Oxford this is her last
summer to teach at Oxford before she
retires from being a professor for good
wow well she's in her 70s here's why I
tell you that same thing
you can do anything
and there was a ton of bumps and bruises
along the way I thought my whole world
had been turned upside down because my
mom walked in and she said hey come here
and she took me into the laundry room
and she put the thing of soap on the
washing machine and said this is how
this works and from here on out you're
on your own and I was like No And you
know what I lived I lived
right yeah I had to get a job I lived
not only did I live but I benefited from
all that stuff
yeah and so your life will change it
will be very different and if you leave
your husband too it's going to be mess
it's going to be heartbreak even though
it's the right thing all those things
you're in a row like you're headed down
a road it's a very very tough road yeah
okay yeah you got to get people in your
life that you trust
for those moments when you have to
Outsource that confidence yes you gotta
get people in your life that you trust
for when you simply don't have the
skills for what comes next and you can
learn them
had you ever before your um your oldest
went to middle school had you ever been
the parent of a middle schooler
no no you learned how to do that right
right you know how to do that yeah yeah
figured it out you ever like know how to
I don't know fix a weird rash on
somebody's butt crack no never do I had
to figure that out that's what happens
when you have kids right you figured it
out you did it yes right yes you will
figure this out too
okay
gonna try I'm gonna try no no hold on
you will
here's the uh one of my favorite
um definitions of imposter syndrome
is I've heard of it yeah it's the fear
that other people are judging me as
harshly as I'm judging myself
I ask you one hard hard hard question
yes yes
and tell me if I'm wrong okay okay
do you doubt yourself because you've
stayed too long
yeah yeah that's partly the reason
is there a reason Chris feels like Chris
let Chris down
or worse you calculate your kids down
yeah I feel really stupid for doing
staying
and letting it get to this point okay
are we done now
yeah we're done okay so let's say
we did stupid things not we're stupid
yeah okay right there's a big difference
guilt is man that was dumb
shame is I am dumb
and you're not dumb you're a woman who
tried to love her husband the best you
could you try to keep your family intact
you try to make sure your kids had a mom
and a dad and you had a husband that
would not let that freaking happen
yeah
and is increasingly putting you in
unsafe unsafe unsafe situations yeah
yeah
that's true that's heroic it's Brave
it's not stupid
yeah okay
yeah has it gone on too long probably
yeah
cool uh yeah yeah it it is
um I think it's I he knows I'm about the
about a job and he's I think he's
getting nervous so
um
yeah oh that makes me sad yeah so he he
tries to change Behavior but I know that
that doesn't ever change so
I've had 16 years to see that so
listen
um whenever you change the equilibrium
in a home
yeah it always does whatever it can to
drag it back to what it was right right
so I'd expect the volume to get like if
nice guy doesn't work then loud guy will
will show up then Timber tantrum guy
will show up yeah and I want you to have
some people in your life that you can
call when you need to go
yeah yeah do you have that
you good it would be difficult but I do
okay every step of the way 100 chance it
will be difficult yeah like it's going
to be difficult so let's just get that
out of the way and then we're gonna go
do what we got to do okay keep our kids
safe keep our ourselves safe keep our
family safe yeah yeah
I'm very very proud of you Chris I'll be
with you every step of the way I want
you to hang on the line I'm going to
send you both of my books my brand new
one
um building a non-anxious life it's it's
kind of what you're talking about how do
I just build something completely new
in a way that there's peace in my house
there's warmth in my house there's
laughter back in my house
there's just not this constant pulse of
electricity I'm gonna send you my first
book own your past change your future
which is about what do you do when it
all falls apart
how do I process what happened when I
was a kid dealing with that old trauma
and then how do I cast that forward and
create something completely new I'm
gonna send you both of those books as my
gift call anytime and I'll walk with you
you got a hard hard road ahead of you
and I am a hundred percent sure you can
do it
I'm proud of you Chris when you don't
have confidence in yourself know at
least one knuckleheaded podcaster does
and I promise you there's a whole bunch
of other folks too